[Music]
[Applause]
mamed
yeah something oh it thank you very
[Music]
[Applause]
much I was just thinking this
morning that imagine if social media
didn't
exist imagine of the pictures and the
videos of of those people in Palestine
and Gaza those children weren't
broadcast throughout the world as they
are
imagine
if the videos and the images of the
father bringing his children in bags
chopped up into little
pieces showing it to the World
Imagine if that had
happened and we couldn't see that that
had happened
imagine if social media if the
internet didn't exist what do you think
the Israelis would be doing right
now there's no doubt that they would
take this as an
opportunity to
obliterate and
annihilate and disseminate all of those
people living in that place man woman
and
child they are already doing this in
plain
sight we are already seeing missiles
come from the sky and dropping raining
down on
children and destroying
lives and we are
seeing that the people now have had
enough of
this and I will was just reading today
the polls in this country of
Norway and I'm glad to announce to you
that only 6% of the population of Norway
wants Israel to continue doing what it's
doing this is a good thing because the
people are different to the governments
and the people all across the world when
they are seeing what they are seeing
they imagine their own children they
imagine their own parents they imagine
their own
grandparents and enough is enough and in
fact we will never forget what they'
done this can never be forgotten we will
never forget what the Israelis decided
to do when they went into Gaza and there
will always be this blemish and this
stain on their reputation they have now
done irreparable damage to
[Applause]
themselves but the question is how do we
move forward the question is what do we
do now it's been over a 100
days and we've been speaking about
boycott and we've been speaking about
ceasefire but I want to say something
else
today which is the
following want to speak to the
politicians here in this country of
Norway because I know they hear what I
say I want to speak to the politicians
and say to them the following your
country itself was occupied in World War
II by the Nazis you know all about
occupation Norway was occupied by the
Nazis and you asked for help now it's
your time to give the help
[Applause]
and I know Norway is a small country but
the people of Norway are a historic
people and Norway played a key role in
the Oslo
Accords so Norway can continue being
front and center in the world stage and
the people of Norway everyone here do
you agree with me that it's time now
that we move
forward do you agree with me that it's
time now to call out the Israelis these
individuals who are destroying the
people once and for
all do you agree with me that Norway and
the Scandinavian countries should take
the front
stage are you ready for
it the people are ready now the
government must do what they are
commissioned to do which is to follow
the will of the
[Applause]
people because the
Israelis they're not even doing a good
job according to their own objectives I
just saw a video of a few Israeli
armymen standing down and getting shot
by
snipers I have to be honest with you
guys I didn't feel sorry for the person
wasn't G did you feel sorry for
them no one feels sorry for baby killers
no one feels sorry for people that
destroy the
civilians but Israel will continue doing
this to its own demise I want to tell
you something this does not help anyone
but the Zionist cause the corrupt
Zionist
cause and so it's not in the interest of
Norway or any other country in Europe to
support such a war and I'm sure looking
at the crowd today and seeing the people
I am sure of a certainty
that Norway will be on the right side of
History do you agree with
me and for us to be on the right side of
History we must ask for what any human
being with compassion and mercy with us
for we are just
saying stop killing our children stop
killing our Innocents stop doing the
immoral and start acting like
[Applause]
[Music]
humans and I'll tell you something
I've never seen such cowardice from an
army as the Israeli
Army how many people have been killed
30,000 40,000 all these children imagine
10,000 children 15,000 children being
killed in front of
you imagine if someone sorry to say my
friend someone came and shot this child
in the head in front of all of us and we
could stop it and no one's stopping it
now we can stop it now we will stop stop
it now we will raise our voices we will
make ourselves
heard let me see you raise your voices
free free freee free
freee free freee I want to hear louder
than that free free free free free free
one more time louder than that free free
free free free
free and with that I will
[Applause]
[Music]
conclude how are you guys doing you've
just seen there some of the scenes of
some of the activism that we've done
with Islam net here in Norway and Islam
net has been very very active with the
pro Palestine cause hasn't it tell us
some of the things that you guys have
done the the Palestinian cause first and
foremost is one of the most important
causes for us to be addressing nowadays
when we're seeing what we're seeing in
Raza happening right now it would be a
shame to stay quiet to be honest so many
people are staying quiet nowadays so
many imams and mash and not to name any
names and we don't want to name in shame
but you know that particular person over
there and
I'm you know I mean there's lots of uh
people that are just afraid of the
consequences what I found quite
inspiring about Islam now and other
organizations like it throughout the
Western world is they haven't feared the
consequences they've been at the front
line haven't they I think any this is
the cause at the moment if if you're not
if you not have the courage to stand up
for the Palestinian cause at this time
and M I think you've done a tremendous
job on P Morgan debating the Shish mly
guy and dismantling dismantling the
Zionist narrative absolutely Al no it's
true alhamdulillah it's all from Allah
subh if you if you can't do that
nowadays is we have to question you your
loyalty to the Islamic cause really and
and that's the Masid that you guys have
been established you guys have been part
of establishing and you've you've played
a massive role in that alhamdulillah we
are doing the Palestinian activism in
our community as well because it's now
the international Muslim Civil Rights
Movement bro and it's we have to think
of all of these things as interconnected
you can't just do daah by itself da and
activism and defending the rights of
Muslims here and abroad all of these
things are in one basket aren't they
they they come together because if you
are saying that we only going to give
daah we're only going to call people to
Islam and we're going to ignore the
Palestinian cause like any tens of
thousands of people Muslims our brother
and are are being Massac and you're
going to ignore that or you going to any
focus on Petty issues where Muslims are
disagreeing and and just completely
disregard that this is the time for
Muslims to come together and stand up
against the injustices that that's been
doing that I think you have a problem so
what it is is that the the Muslim civil
rights movement has been has been
fantastic so already we're seeing some
changes in laws in Sweden we have seen
some things some changes in laws Vis A
the B burning of the Quran and these
kind of things and that's come off the
back of some of the campaigns that the
Islam have done in Scandinavia isn't it
without a shadow of a doubt and just
putting out information about what's
happening uh with the Quran burning and
all of that stuff and the pressure we're
actually putting on the government it it
shows that the pressure from the Muslim
World it has had an effect to an extent
that obviously any Islam that can't take
all the credit but the um as a whole
would take the credit for that the
erdogan and what he has pressured the
Swedish government that if you don't
stop the burning of the Quran we're not
going to let you inate unfortunately any
I think he has been lack he's been
slacking on that specific point right
now but at the end of the day what I'm
saying that if the Muslims they keep
putting that pressure and keep standing
up for their rights and just say that
we're not accepting this anymore it's
been taken too far I think the way
you're doing it is perfect and and the
the the thing I like about Islam n why I
keep supporting them is that they have a
multifaceted approach on the one hand
you got the wak you've got which is an
investment project which now uh funds a
big part of the da organization and
funds all these events and all these
activities in the daa center and the
Masjid and all these things on the other
hand you have what we have here which is
the social media Outlet uh program which
is kind of like an outreach program then
you have a serious activism program now
which is part and partial part of the
work I mean would you agree with that
without a Shadow of Doubt and that's
actually why I would say any if you guys
want to reap the rewards of the great
work that we're doing together
collectively I think it's time if you
haven't become one of the Loyalists they
have to become the loyalist now yeah
it's it's time that you become a regular
supporter of the dawa of the Islamic
cause because what it is it's a trickle
down effect and and for example from my
understanding Islam there they've
actually been helping fun raise funds
for Palestine yes now there's two things
you could say you could say to raise
funds for Palestine directly which we've
all been doing and it's a very good
thing to do but it's a better thing to
set up those organizations which can
help raise funds for Palestine help do
the activism for Palestine help do the
activism of the Muslim people in the
west help do all these kind of things I
think this kind of investment is
incredible absolutely
because to raise ra the actual funding
for those in need in Palestine is one
very important aspect of the whole
picture but at the same time the
intellectual aspect addressing their
criticism and and raising awareness for
the Palestinian cause and teaching
Muslims about the history of Palestine
and giving them the arguments that they
can use to present and debate in with in
their social Gatherings to change the
narrative that's what we need to do as
well so brothers and sisters if you guys
become a part of this organization
Muhammed hijab Islam net myself and all
of us you we are collectively doing that
raising awareness we're all together
we're one hand and I'll tell you what I
mean this is an opportunity of a
lifetime let's take a look at I was just
looking and we shouldn't compare maybe
we shouldn't compare but I was looking
at some of the organizations that the
zionists have okay sorry to say but if
you look for example at um The Daily
wire so to say we're talking about
hundreds of millions of dollars bro
exactly hundreds of millions of dollars
maybe billions at this point billions of
dollars we're not talking about that
money here we're saying that give us 10%
of that if Islam net has 10% of that
they'll invest it in the right places do
the right things and what you'll see is
process on the streets fundraising
messages being built uh people being
educated this this is what we need to do
we need to be able to respond and the
best way we can do it is through funding
these projects I think after hearing
this honestly after hearing this if
they're not clicking the link and
spending 30 seconds of their time to do
the right thing I think uh there's a
question that they need to ask
themselves which is am I sincere am I do
I really care about this do I care about
this situation or not that Allah's word
is the higher most but I think they do
care and I think they will care and I
think they will click the link and
that's what they're going to do now it's
what it 10 seconds to fill out the form
yeah maybe something like that oh my God
go quickly inshah oh my God it's about
having the right mindset if you're not
willing to invest for your and become a
loyal supporter of the Islamic cause
then there's an issue Allah says in
Quran he
says it says that oh some of you have
been called some of you have been
called to give in the sake of Allah give
Sak in the sake of Allah and some of you
will be stinged so Allah saying this no
not not Islam not this one or not that
one or that these are the words of Allah
words of Allah that's what Allah subh
says in the
Quran that if you turn around if you
turn away that Allah will replace you
with a people not like you and they
won't be like you so may Allah make us
of those people who Allah chooses and
the way to choose to be chosen by Allah
is to choose Allah and the way to choose
Allah is to click the link below and
That's the Way
[Music]
Forward